bonjour guillaume bigot merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
objectif de cette mesure de bercy et la
souveraineté de la france appelée de ses
voeux par emmanuel macron lors de ses
dernières allocutions et ce alors que
des entreprises françaises de masques
par exemple en bretagne où luxe faire
pour l'oxygène les oxygen des
respirateurs ont fermé un dernièrement
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
cette mesure de bercy comme une
gesticulation ou par c'est une sorte de
souverainisme peau de lapin et c'est une
sorte de en parler des ouvriers de la
25e heure où des résistants de la
dernière heure c'est exactement ça il
faut faire un peu d'agitation
en réalité la souveraineté et sur cette
question notamment des des médicaments
type curare des respirateurs des masques
l'enjeu n'est pas disons la maîtrise des
capitaux l'enjeu c'est la maîtrise du
travail
c'est où sont produits ces éléments et
non pas s'il y a des investissements
étrangers d'ailleurs il est plutôt
souhaitable qu'il y ait des
investissements étrangers
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est ou et
le travail et vous sont les centres de
production dans un certain nombre de
productions dites stratégique vital et
la sécurité alimentaire la sécurité
sanitaire et bien sûr la sécurité tout
court
c'est à dire les enjeux militaires etc
j'ajoute que ce n'est pas du tout une
initiative française
là aussi c'est un phénomène cosmétiques
auquel nous a habitué le gouvernement
français c'est le gouvernement français
ce n'est plus depuis très longtemps
qu'une caisse enregistreuse en réalité
des volontés de bruxelles la commission
de bruxelles la commission européenne a
dans ses orientations déjà depuis deux
ans invité les états membres de l'union
européenne à protéger des actifs dits
stratégiques et avait inclus la santé et
la recherche des technologies
l'allemagne avait mis en oeuvre depuis
2018 en abaissant à 10% pour les
entreprises dans le secteur l'italie et
même étendue aux de l'assurance en
baissant à 5%
j'ajoute qu'il n'est pas du tout besoin
d'être à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne pour avoir des mesures de ce
type là grande-bretagne la suisse israël
la corée
tous les pays sérieux le faut et enfin
ce qui était celle étrange dans cette
histoire de souveraineté européenne
puisqu'elle est proclamée à l'échelle de
l'union européenne
tout le monde avec un peu de bon sens
peut comprendre que les alliances
stratégique se font à l'échelle mondiale
volkswagen était lié à cordes ford n'est
pas européen mais américain bmw italia t
sainteté sainte n'est pas européen mais
chinois renom est allié à nissan nissan
n'est pas européen n'est japonais donc
tout ça n'a pas de sens c'est simplement
si vous voulez dire qu'on agit dire
qu'on fait quelque chose en fait on se
contente de mettre en oeuvre des
instructions de bruxelles qui n'ont rien
changé la dépendance stratégique de la
france
alors le gouvernement redoutant une
réduction de la valeur boursière de
certaines entreprises
comment est ce qu'il est il faut trouver
un point d'équilibré centre à la fois le
protectionnisme et la terre d'accueil
pour les investisseurs ce que c'est un
double jeu vous parlez de l'union
européenne
quels sont les seuils justement à ne pas
dépasser pour éviter des procès en
protectionnisme justement face à l'union
européenne
d'abord on ne peut pas parler de
protectionnisme de protection que le
protectionnisme a une connotation c'est
un peu pop up le populisme protection
protectionnisme la protection c'est
positif
le protectionnisme c'est pas très
intelligent si c'est appliquer de
manière indiscriminée et systématique et
c'est là on perd finalement le dirait la
lys cokerie intellectuelle de ce
discours parce que on laisse à penser on
crie on fait croire à l'opinion publique
qu'une protections ciblées et
intelligentes de ses actifs ciblés
intelligente aussi des importations de
biens et ciblées et intelligentes de la
production se serait finalement
automatiquement un arrêt complet des
échanges avec l'extérieur mais
évidemment c'est pas possible en l'état
actuel des traités à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne vous ne pouvez pas
protégé de toute façon vous ne pouvez
pas vous protéger contre les
importations et donc pas par voie de
conséquence ne pourrait pas reprendre la
production sur votre sol d'un certain
nombre de biens qui sont stratégiques
dont effectivement le certains
médicaments dont du matériel militaire
et dont dix ont ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme vital pour l'avenir un
certain nombre de technologies
un décret était entré en vigueur le 1er
avril
renier mais bruno le maire a rajouté
donc ces nouvelles mesures protectrices
pour les entreprises françaises
est ce que c'est un signe de panique est
ce que c'est la bonne stratégie à
adopter
qu'est ce que vous feriez mais ne dit
pas c'est pas du tout hein hein ça va
pas du tout nous protéger il faut bien
comprendre qu'il s'agit simplement de
réduire un petit peu la part
d'investissement étranger de la part que
les investisseurs étrangers peuvent
prendre dans le contrôle du capital
d'entreprises en france
mais la question centrale c'est quelles
sont les entreprises qui restent en
france et ça le sujet donc la seule
chose que vous pouvez faire pour refaire
revenir finalement la production à
l'intérieur de la france c'est d'opérer
des 10 ajustements sur certains produits
encore une fois il s'agit pas du tout
d'un protectionnisme généralisé qui
serait complètement absurde mais de
manière ciblée de faire en sorte que des
produits soit taxé à l'importation
c'est aussi simple que ça ce que font
tous les pays du monde sauf les pays qui
sont rentrés dans cette sorte de départ
historique qui s'appellent union
européenne merci guillaume bigot d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes politologue et essayiste